okay so we want to address this this is
a really a big deal you know in this
episode we called the hotel in
Cincinnati and get people the exact room
number where the Cincinnati fart
occurred and there's there was a little
you know misunderstanding as far as a
what I heard and what was repeated back
and we're not yet at the exact room
number we need to figure it out right
and I want to be I'm gonna come clean on
a little something so when we when the
Cincinnati fart happened and we recorded
that episode August 2015
right and we said oh it's room 1618 and
I remember in my head going wait that's
not the right room that was I think your
parents room okay now so yeah and I'm
like what cuz I know at the time I go
that's not right I said that in my head
so either it's 6:18 or 808 or 808 and
we're not giving up that's the thing we
just wanted people to know like we're
gonna find out the correct room number
we're just we're just not there yet we
don't want to mislead anyone and we
don't want you to think that we're just
gonna quit on the room we don't want you
to plan your summer vacations around
yes information look it is the
Renaissance Hotel in downtown Cincinnati
yeah and it is either 808 or 618 I'm
almost inclined to believe but not 1618
right I wanted the numbers right because
she said we listened back and she
clearly said six I'd say 16 I want to
say it's 808 because of the band 808
state yes an industrial band I remember
being like who at always state in my
head at the time yeah you know when you
make dough Association maybe you could
check in and say can I get two keys one
for 808 run for 618 and just walk around
both for a moment Malins see if you
smell anything yeah or just stand there
close your eyes
if you feel a little extra movement
you're in the right room you know the
energy we're gonna do a little more
research and figure out yeah correct
room yeah
well make sure you guys do the right go
to the right room yeah the right things
you know yeah this is a big deal yeah
this is a big deal well I know and we're
commemorating it it's very important I
think would be able to figure out the
correct room by looking back at our
flights and figuring out exactly who
checked in first you checked in first
and I flew in as late as I could we went
to the wedding and then I left the next
day no button you stayed on a day after
my know but I don't know that I checked
into that did I check into that hotel
first you came from another room you
know we started fresh together in that
rather than their room it see it's
stopped so I don't know if you were if
you were in a different hotel I was what
I'm trying to tell you okay I wasn't a
different hotel unuq one what day was
the wedding the wedding was on a Friday
I think well all we have to do is look
at the calendar we can look at the
calendar and figure it out yeah can I
came as late as possible I came in the
night before the wedding I believe no no
I came for the dinner yeah yeah okay
mystery we're gonna have to it's a bit
of a mystery here let's look right now
August it was what day Saturday August
22nd of 2015 is a Saturday okay yeah
look here flight I flew from CVG to LAX
on the 22nd on Saturday on Saturday from
CVG so I flew in from LAX to CVG on the
19th so I checked into the hotel on the
19th you wouldn't have checked in on the
19th let the record show unless this is
your flesh mug how would I have that in
my phone that you know it's me
confirmation croud look it's all here
Christine you flew in Wednesday oh that
makes sense because the rehearsals
Thursday the weddings Friday and
Saturday which means it was the first
room number she gave us the 19 which I
think was 808 guys
the Cincinnati fart happened in 808
and I know we make a correction to the
episode it's a very nice title it
correctly because I know the day we
recorded it on the show we said it wrong
and in my head I went should I say the
right number and I was like who cares
you know maybe we should just tack this
onto the episode right
but can we tag this audio onto the
episode maybe you know eight information
yeah
gosh I'm really happy we were able to
resolve this yeah if you want you could
address the fact that there's a diaper
in front of you on the table I don't
know anymore what's going in there this
is a dog diaper
I got an Amazon using our banner your
mom's house podcast calm this is to
deter the dog from urinating on our
staircase because there's it's carpeted
for people that are curious too she
doesn't pee in it no she just does he
until she goes outside where we take it
off right it's part of potty training
and yes she's housebroken for the most
part she's just young she's stupid
sit all right guys Cincinnati fart room
808 it's 808 808 its 808